good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight when democratic
politicians across this country all of a
sudden started to pull back their mask
mandates he did it virtually overnight
and of course they did it in unison we
naturally assumed that new polling had
to be behind it someone at the dnc must
have seen terrifying public opinion
numbers and decided to abandon project
quarantine before the midterm elections
that made sense to us we explained that
theory in the show last night we still
think it's probably pretty true
but it's also clear as of tonight that
there is another explanation for this
democrats in this country are looking
north to their friends in the ruling
party of canada and what they see there
scares them
canada's working class has finally
rebelled after years of relentless abuse
truck drivers are threatening to topple
justin trudeau's creepy little
government with their big rigs and they
may succeed actually the protests
against justin trudeau's vaccine
mandates have been far more effective
than anyone in charge imagined for
democrats in the united states that's a
pretty obvious lesson
over the past 48 hours canadian truckers
have blocked the major trade routes
between their country and ours
last night farmers driving heavy
agricultural equipment shut down the
highways at the manitoba border with the
united states you're seeing footage now
from the town of emerson manitoba
1100 miles away a similar scene on the
border of ontario in the united states
green tractors with canadian flags
lining the highway in protest
but the most meaningful blockade of all
is taking place right now on the
ambassador bridge that's the privately
owned span that connects detroit to
windsor ontario
if you live in the upper midwest you
know it well a quarter of all the trade
between the united states and canada one
another's biggest trading partners
that's billions of dollars comes across
that bridge and as fox's molly line is
reporting from ottawa that bridge is now
completely shut down
we're canadian and we want to be free
canadians increasing concerns spreading
through canada and now the u.s as the
freedom convoy threatens trade along the
border
[Applause]
truckers blocking traffic at the
ambassador bridge connecting detroit and
ontario a second crossing linking
alberta and montana also shut down by
protesters calling for an end to all
coveted restrictions and vaccine
mandates we want freedom freedom of all
mandates
and that's what we're fighting for the
ambassador bridge is the busiest
international crossing in north america
carrying 25 percent of all trade between
canada and the u.s
we want freedom the truckers are saying
freedom from mandates it's a very
straightforward ask but so far the
truckers don't have that freedom and so
their blockade continues so far that
blockade has forced the ford motor
company to shut down one of its
manufacturing plants and to operate
another plant with a skeleton crew
toyota says it won't be able to
manufacture vehicles in ontario for the
rest of the week general motors has
cancelled multiple shifts at its plant
in lansing michigan due to part
shortages
so this protest is less than a week old
and already is causing deep pain to at
least one global industry
it's hard to overstate the historical
significance of what we're watching
right here the canadian trucker convoy
is the single most successful human
rights protest in a generation if
nothing else it has been a very useful
reminder to our entitled ruling class
the working-class men can be pushed but
only so far
when they push back it hurts
it turns out that truck drivers are more
important to a country's future than say
diversity consultants or even msnbc
contributors who knew
the white house has no interest in
knowing according to the associated
press tonight the bite administration is
quote urging the trudeau government to
quote use its federal powers to stop
this protest to end the trucker's
protest in other words crush them by
force
politico is reporting that biden
officials are coordinating with canadian
authorities to quote establish alternate
traffic routes around the protesters
that's scranton joe the pro-union guy
shutting down a labor action
pete but a judge is the completely
incompetent transportation secretary in
this country apparently he's in charge
of this effort what mayor pete does not
realize is it's not so easy truck
drivers know a lot more about roads than
mckinsey consultants do
an alternative border crossing in
alberta for example has already been
totally shut down they thought of that
already mayor pete the blue water bridge
which connects ontario to port huron
michigan has been reporting delays
tonight of nearly five hours
now there is an obvious way to fix this
problem matthew maroon who's the owner
of the ambassador bridge into michigan
just spelled it out for justin trudeau
who's not terribly bright
and the vaccine mandates and the bridge
reopens it's not hard
but justin trudeau won't
and he's decided he doesn't have to
because the truckers as he's explained
have no legitimate complaint
they're racists so we're not required to
listen to them here is trudeau in the
canadian parliament on monday
the people of ottawa don't deserve to be
harassed in their own neighborhoods
they don't deserve to be confronted with
the inherent violence of a swastika
flying on a street corner
or a confederate flag
or the insults
and jeers
just because they're wearing a mask
that's not who canada who canadians are
oh so they're not even really canadians
they're nazis so you don't have to hear
anything they say they don't even belong
here maybe we'll intern them or expel
them
trudeau state broadcasters have been
repeating these lies over and over and
over again for maximum effect pravda
parroting brezhnev that's what they do
what's striking however is that the
media in our country claim to be
independent but they've been doing the
very same thing watch
some of the organizers of this protest
which as i mentioned started more than a
week ago they do want to overthrow the
government canadian officials calling
the situation a quote nationwide
insurrection the police chief says covet
protests are a quote nationwide
insurrection driven by madness a
nationwide insurrection driven by
madness and just think of the language i
know it sounds familiar to you right a
threat to democracy an insurrection
sedation the police say that they are
under resourced and they are overwhelmed
they have said that this city is under
siege it's not just truckers there's a
lot of i've heard there's q anon
supporters in the crowd residents that i
have spoken to who say they feel
terrorized intimidated it's
a
cult
they're cueing on supporters in the
crowd it's a cult
they're nazis and they're crazy
insurrectionists on the edmund pettus
bridge
imagine
now they're using these smears because
typically they work just dismiss these
people don't listen to them they didn't
go to college
but what justin trudeau apparently
didn't count on is that a handful of
independent journalists are committing
journalism inside canada and a free
press works that's why we have it or did
so instead of repeating state mandated
talking points like their journalists do
and the morons in our press corps do
these independent reporters have been
broadcasting hours-long interviews with
the truckers themselves in their cabs
totally unfiltered so you can decide
what you think you can actually make
your own judgment about reality so you
watch these streams for just a few
minutes and you realize that these
truckers whatever their faults may be
are far less odious and much harder
working than the journalists and the
politicians who call them nazis
here's one 24 year old protester who
saved up and bought his own truck he's
an owner operator now he's losing
hundreds of dollars every day because
he's no longer working but he says it's
worth it because he's more concerned
about human rights than about his own
paycheck you decide i agree with the
freedom of choice so
people should be if you want to wear if
you want to wear a diaper over your face
say go ahead you know
you can wear a face diaper if you want
but
um why should i
because of your fear
i gotta wear that garbage on my face you
know doing that for for two years
they said two weeks but
um
it's turned into two years so enough is
enough
yeah the voice of the working man there
you know how he knows a nazi because he
used the word freedom
now that footage of course was not shot
by the cbc which is canadian state media
the most dishonest of all it was from a
live stream on the youtube channel zot
it was filmed just after midnight this
morning zod is run by a man you've never
heard of called matt garcia garcia is
one of a handful of independent youtube
channel operators who are doing what
legacy media refuses to do anywhere ever
anymore
garcia actually talks to people he
reports he's not paid to do this he's
doing because nobody else will do it
you should watch it it's compelling
because you can hear people speak and
you can decide what you think about what
they have to say
here's another protester that garcia
spoke to in the streets of ottawa this
man says that justin trudeau's
authoritarian behavior reminds him of
the ayatollahs in the country he left
which is iran watch
i'm from iran and
i am proud to be between the
freedom-loving
canadian patriots
no i came here from uh toronto
i did a speech on the stage and
i lost my freedom once in iran by the
ayatollahs by the mullahs
i don't want to lost my freedom again in
canada
so what's the answer to him is he in q
anon is he a nazi is he a white
supremacist
canada's leaders have no response
whatsoever that it secures all these
people of bigotry and then they turn
away the protesters are so immoral we
have no obligation to listen to them
because democracy
we all lose when they do that because
actually the truckers do have something
to say and some of them are pretty
articulate some of them are even
eloquent about what they want so as a
public service we thought you'd like to
hear it here it is
it's nothing extreme about wanting
people to be able to make their own
decisions in their home that is the best
decision for their families there's
nothing extreme about that
no that's not extreme if you want to see
extremism take a close look at how
canada's ruling class is responding to
these decidedly non-extreme protests
authorities in canada are now stealing
firewood from protesters in sub-zero
temperatures you're seeing that theft on
your screen right now we're not making
it up
now that wood is not being used in a
crime they're not using it to rob liquor
stores the protesters are using the wood
to keep from freezing to death in
february
but trudeau's enforcers just took it
from him them they also seized fuel
which the truckers were using to keep
from dying in their cabs overnight watch
you take those cans off of that truck
is that your property
it is now
so you have the right to take gas cans
off of a trucker's truck is that correct
it is correct according to what
aiding a betting criminal
a criminal offense
so
now when you have gas cans on your truck
it's a criminal offense this guy's name
is trudeau
so let's say you were on american
television or you worked at the
brookings institution or the atlantic
council or you were liz cheney or any
one of the many people who lecture you
every day about democracy
what would you make of that exchange now
you may not like the guy's beard or you
may not like who he voted for
but what's your answer to him
if police are breaking the law
by enforcing an order from the guy who
runs the country
is that a democracy no it's not it's not
a free country it's a very scary place
and that's exactly what canada has
become under justin trudeau we'll play
just one more clip there are a lot of
these but we're not going to drag it out
you see the point watch this one
these are police acting under justin
trudeau's orders dragging an elderly man
to jail and hurting him along the way
why because he dared to honk his horn in
support of the truckers
what's your name and badge number
an old man
a canadian citizen
it's communism
this is communism he's scared
communist you stand with the communist
arrested an old man
shame on you
shame on you
they heard him too
look up his bruises on the internet
so in the end canadians are nice people
the cliche is true and they're seeing
some of this it's being hidden from them
on their state media but it's all on the
internet
so justin trudeau is attacking human
rights and attacking humans
and that ultimately is bound to provoke
a backlash and it is the province of
alberta just announced is lifting its
coveted restrictions and scrapping its
vaccine passport system completely
saskatchewan quebec prince edward island
have done the same they're getting rid
of most of their covet restrictions in
the face of this in response to this
when you go too far as ceausescu learned
people turn against you it was just a
few days ago that a guy called jagmeet
singh he's the leader of canada's
supposedly pro-worker ndp party smeared
the truckers as racist of course quote
those that claim the superiority of the
white bloodline what up pig
it's always the same lie
but yesterday even jagmeet singh finally
realized the same old slander doesn't
work anymore so he went to plan b
he went for a federal plan to quote exit
the pandemic in other words he caved in
the face of principled human rights
protests that's how that works
several members of justin trudeau's own
liberal party are now rebuking justin
trudeau one of those lawmakers a member
of parliament called joelle lightbound
described justin trudeau's vaccine
mandates as quote an attempt to wedge to
divide and to stigmatize i fear that
this politization of the pandemic risks
undermining the public's trust in our
public health institutions oh you think
yeah we in america know a little bit
about that who will trust a doctor when
the smoke settles from corona seriously
but on a political level anyone watching
this understands just how profound the
betrayal is the betrayal both in canada
and in the united states self-described
liberals the ones who've lectured you
for decades about the nobility of
organized labor
are now taking the side of management of
strike breakers over striking workers
they're applauding like mr burns on the
simpsons as cops harass and abuse
strikers and their families pretty soon
they'll be demanding scabs
literally if they aren't already
it's so deeply revealing
scratch a liberal and you'll find a
fascist
today on twitter an obama dhs official
called juliet kyam called for violence
against the truckers slash their tires
she demanded but don't stop there quote
cancel their insurance suspend their
driver's licenses prohibit any future
regulatory certification for truckers
etc have we learned nothing fellow
members of the ruling class these things
fester when there are no consequences
crush them before they get big ideas
now juliet kayem is a nasty little
fascist and of course she's a cnn
contributor too of course she is
but we will concede juliet caim is right
about one thing
these things do fester
when you ignore the population's
legitimate concerns for long enough
when you diminish your dismiss your own
citizens as racists and conspiracy nuts
and trying to shut them down for long
enough
at some point they are apt to revolt
once people realize
they're citizens not serfs you can't
really know where things go from there
and in that vein tonight a group of
american truckers announced they will
begin a nationwide truck convoy in this
country starting next month in protest
against joe biden's vaccine mandates
that rally will begin in southern
california on march 5th and then it will
progress eastward by truck to washington
dc a city they still perhaps naively
assume is the capital of their country
how does the supposedly pro-union white
house feel about this they're completely
panicked working-class people expressing
their opinions that's not allowed
so joe biden taking a page from justin
trudeau his friend to the north has
already set the department of homeland
security to work to shut them down
we'll be covering that in some detail
there is some drama ahead hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else